foreign
comes from Jeremy in Pennsylvania I am
doing a will I'm 55 years old and have a
wife and two adult children I'm split
between leaving everything to my wife or
going ahead and leaving things to my
kids as well there are certain things I
want my kids to have but I don't want my
wife to think that I don't trust her to
carry out my wishes if I proceed her
is it weird not to leave everything to
my wife
um
I mean not necessarily it is her money
too though I mean like it's not just
your money and your stuff it's you guys
together but I think if you were to say
hey when I you know if I pass away
what would you how much you know what
does it look like for your life you know
this is you talking to your wife of what
do things look like for you what um what
will you have will you be taken care of
making sure she's your priority first
because your adult children
or second in that and then if everything
is fine and good like I'm okay with you
saying okay you know do we want to get
leave them
you know x amount in X amounts but all
of that is communicated with her because
this is her money too that's what I
would say there's two things built into
your question that are disturbing the
way you State this is almost like
there's a possibility this is your
second wife and these kids aren't hers
and if that's the case then
um you know then you've got to have this
discussion and go I am going to leave
you this amount to take care of you and
this amount for them because I want to
do that if that's the case if not the
other thing that may be hidden in here
is there's like some reason that you
feel like she's not going to do this
like she's been irresponsible or you all
haven't been unified in your decision
making on money and so you have a reason
to kind of worry that she's not going to
follow through on your wishes
um if that's the case then that's
another issue that's different than a
will that's a marriage issue a trust
issue that you've got to get into yeah
for sure yeah and so
um that that's two possibilities I mean
the third possibility is as simple as
um these are her kids her kids and um
you can do whatever you want to do with
your money but it's also hers as Rachel
stated so we ought to talk about this
and just figure it out together what's
you know what is your motivation on that
and primary is that she's taken care of
if you don't leave her enough to have a
wonderful life because you gave too much
to your kids your grown kids strange
that wouldn't I would not agree with
that yeah uh your your primary
responsibility is to her okay so what I
just thought of this question is we are
talking this out if you did have a
second marriage
and all grown kids or even T I mean
maybe even well I'd say grown kids yeah
what is the what is the responsibility
if someone is bringing in money to a
marriage
and they are one now yeah but she has
four adult kids and he has two and it
they're later in line you know what I
mean like does he have responsibility to
leave money to those four kids or it's
going to be left to her so she's
probably gonna you know what I mean like
it's really complicated yeah because uh
you know second marriage could be 25
years long
you know it could be longer than the
first yep and
um wouldn't be that unusual uh and so uh
and you know the grown kids are all okay
and he wants first to make sure his new
wife is taken care of that wouldn't be
bad yeah wouldn't be bad sure so you
just got to think that through but
there's no inherent
entitlement
that these grown kids are in tight adult
children are entitled uh morally
ethically spiritually none of that
um and
um it's It's Not Unusual in the in a
situation with a stepmom as an example
uh for the adult kids to resent her
getting anything mm-hmm
and that's a sense of entitlement that
is wrong yeah that sense of entitlement
is wrong but uh so like I've got a a
wealthy friend who's in his 70s I got
remarried and
um recently and I don't know what his
estate plan is but his kids are
perfectly his grown kids are perfectly
functional yep they don't need anything
yep uh so you know where I in his
situation I will make sure she's taken
care of and I want to leave some to them
yeah uh but uh and he's got the the you
know the ability to do both in that case
so but what's primary I I think your
spouse is probably gonna be primary even
then yeah uh if you had to look do you
think the step kids are entitled too
yeah not necessarily not yeah I mean
that's almost prenup stuff yeah yeah uh
but it's it's it's the complications of
Yours Mine and Ours and uh it requires
even that much more uh constant
communication in discussion about the
estate plan you know so like your
brother and your husband are in a state
planning meeting with me and your mom
tomorrow you know and Winston is you
know is not in my bloodline but he's
married to you and uh handles a lot of
our real estate and so yeah we're going
to be there tomorrow talking through you
know some changes what we're doing but
you know what's that look like
everybody's got to be in it you know
everybody's got to know what's going on
I'm getting cut out of the wheel Dave no
he's getting cut out of the well really
you know changes it's so freaking
complicated we have to review it ever so
often yeah no totally to make sure we
remember what we said we were doing and
I think it's that's another piece to
this too that I think is important
another element is as an adult child
right as we all are but
that's why doing this in your 20s your
30s or 40s is setting your own family up
right regardless of where your parents
depend upon your parents or any
messiness that comes out of wills and
all of this like that you are in a
position that you're taking care of
yourself yeah and that and any of that's
just gravy yes yes gravy on the biscuit
that's exactly right and then the second
thing that comes out another point that
comes out of this discussion is hey you
need a will yes everybody does and 78 of
Americans die without oil stupid
it's just stupid get your will done go
to Mama legal mama bearlegalforms.com
get your will done the second thing is
tell everybody what's going to happen
like if you've got
step children we're talking about her
kids and she did not bring wealth into
the marriage or she did and they're
going to get hers but they're not going
to get yours tell them yep tell them so
you know or or tell them I'm gonna take
tell your kids I'm going to take care of
my new wife
with this and whatever's left over
you're gonna get and so they don't go
well I'm dead
go ahead and get all that out of the way
you know let's just tell everybody where
it is go ahead and have a reading of the
will and if somebody's gonna be pissed
off let them do it while you're alive
yep you know and another question we get
all the time is how do I help my parents
talk about this stuff how do I get my
parents to do a will how do I start
these kind of conversations because of
importance so if that if you are in that
situation that wasn't one of my FPU
classes that I when I coordinated it
we're done now but one of the questions
that came through a week ago yeah was a
lady that um she said that she was like
I my husband's parents told him that
he's going to have to be the executor of
everything but he didn't know what's in
it and he didn't you know and so I'm
like sitting down and saying hey we want
we want this communicated really clearly
so that your wishes are granted and your
legacy how you want it is to be you know
to be honest I refuse to be the executor
of something and I don't know what it is
yeah that's asinine it's a secret but we
want you to be in charge of the secret
no not a chance not signing up for your
toxic BS no thank you and that's exactly
what was going on yeah so no we're not
doing that we're going to sit down
everybody's gonna know we're all going
to talk about it and then I can actually
I don't care if I get any money I'm not
after the money I just want to help you
execute your wishes that's what the
executor does is execute your wishes
secrets and your toxic BS not a chance
not doing that